all right where we left off we really
were in the home stretch and now we just
have this messy arithmetic that we have
to solve to essentially find our slope
and then we'll be able to figure out the
y-intercept and since we're actually
going to have to take the square root of
this eventually let's just factor each
of these terms and see if this hopefully
will simplify into something reasonable
into something reasonable so let's just
look at the let's just factor 104 i
think it'll be useful just to have each
of these guys factored so 104
is the same thing as 4
as 4 times 4 times 26
right 4 times 25 is 100 4 times 26 which
is the same thing as 2 times
two times
thirteen so that's a hundred and four so
104 squared let's just worry about the
radical right now so this is going to be
this squared so it's going to be four
times four times two times two
times thirteen times 13 that's this
right over here i squared it so i put
each of its factors twice and then
you're going to have plus 4
plus 4 times let's factor 495.
495.
it's divisible by 5. let's see 5 goes
into 500 5 goes into 500 100 times this
is 5 less than that it's going to be 99
99 is 9 times
9 times 11. so the 495
the 495 can be factored as 5 times 9
times 11
and then 400
400 is pretty straightforward 400 is
going to be times 4 times 4
times 10 times 10 times 10 times 10. and
so we can factor out for this expression
right here under the radical sign
there is a common factor of 4 times 4
here we have a 4
times 4 and there doesn't look to be any
other common factor so this is going to
be the square root of 16
times the square root
times the square root of
as this is it looks like we're actually
going to have to do some serious
multiplication here the square root of 4
times
4 times 169 so let's just multiply that
out
so we're going to have this is really a
painful problem so let's just write
let's just say this four times let's see
13 times 13 is 169.
so we're gonna have 169
169. that's the 13 times 13 times 4
times 4 so 4 times 9 is 36
6 times 4 is 24 plus 3 is 27
1 times 4 is 4 plus 2 is 6. so
all of this right over here is going to
be 676
676 and then we're going to have let's
see five times
well five times not well we know what
this is right over here this this number
right over here is going to be 495
and we're going to multiply that we're
going to multiply that times
100 so this is going to be so plus
495 and just add two zeros one two so
becomes forty nine thousand
five hundred so this is going to become
this is going to become square root of
16 is four
times the square root this will be
interesting we're going to do some
serious factoring here of 49 500 plus
676 is going to be fifty thousand
fifty thousand let me see so
six six fifty thousand
one hundred and
seventy six right if this was just a
five hundred here then we would get to
fifty thousand we have another 176 so
times the square root of this crazy
thing and so let's see if we can factor
this
let's see if we can factor this this is
really
really a nasty problem so 50 000 it
looks like it's divisible looks like
it's divisible by four so let's see four
goes into fifty thousand one hundred and
seventy six we're getting some good
practice here on our arithmetic four
goes into fifty maybe there's a faster
way to do this
twelve times twelve times four
twelve times four is forty eight
you get subtract you get a 21 4 goes
into 21 five times you get a 20 subtract
you get a 17 4 goes into 17
4 times 4 times 4 is 16 subtract bring
down that you get a 16. so it goes 12
54 times
and once again this looks like it's
divisible by four or definitely is
divisible by four and let's see we could
this is going to be i don't want to make
any careless mistakes so let me just
divide it again
i'm tempted to do some of this in my
head but we've gotten so far i don't
want to make mistakes so 4 goes into 12
3 times 3 times 4 is 12 4 goes into 5
one time 1 times 4 is 4. you have 14 4
goes into 14 3 times 3 times 4 is 12
you get a 2 24.
so 31
136 once again this looks like it's
divisible by 4 again this is 4 times
i should have just guessed that this
whole thing was going to be divisible by
16 or something so 4 goes into don't
want to make a careless mistake 3136
4 goes into 31 7 times you get a 28
subtract you get a three 33 goes into it
eight times you get a 32 subtract you
get a 16 you go exactly four times no
remainder so 7
once again this looks like it is
divisible by four it's getting at least
simpler now four goes into seven hundred
and eighty-four fourteen seven one time
four
you get a 38 it goes here nine times
nine times four is 36 you subtract you
get a 24
times and really if you are going to
take the je i i do recommend being able
to do this mental arithmetic much faster
because
i'm clearly not capable of doing it fast
enough so you have 196 and then 196 this
is divisible by 16 i believe let me see
16 goes into 196
it goes into it actually no it's not so
let's just do by four this is 17 i
believe let me look at just four my
brain is fried 196 4 times 16
36 it goes into four goes into 36
nine times so this is four times 49
all right so if we're taking the square
root of the square root of all of this
business this is 4 times 49 over here so
this is the square root of 4 to the
fifth power this is four to the fifth
power so or let's just do it this way we
could just take the square root of each
of these factors so this in blue so this
is going to become four times
the square root of this we could just
take the square root of each of its
factors so it's going to be one two
three four five twos so times two to the
fifth which is 32 times the square root
of 49 which is
seven so this term right over here
simplify two this whole product this
whole video has been just arithmetic
four times my brain really is fried so
32 times four we have an eight four
times three is one hundred and twenty
four times three is twelve and then we
want to multiply that times seven i
think you could see my handwriting
degrade
7 times 8 is 56
is 56
7 times 2 is 14
plus 5 is 19.
bring up the one seven times one is
seven so it's 896.
so all of that stuff in blue was 896.
so let's see all of this stuff over here
all of this stuff over here was
896.
896. now we have to decide to do plus or
minus remember we want a positive slope
so we want to add the 896. so we we're
getting m squared
is equal to 104 plus 896 or negative 104
plus 896. so if we subtract 104 from
this business over here we're going to
get we're going to get 700.
792 right 792 over
over
990 this is what m squared is equal to
and then this looks
this looks let's see it's a divisible
this these are both divisible by nine so
let's divide both of them by nine let me
clear all of this stuff down here it's
just a big arithmetic video
but hopefully we'll get the right answer
it'd be painful if i made a careless
mistake earlier on and all of this is in
vain and i have to redo the video so
let's
let's hope that isn't the case so let's
divide both of these by nine nine goes
into
792 it goes into 79
it goes into 79 eight times 8 times 9 is
72 and then you get 72 so it goes 88
times
so this is if you divide that by 9 you
get 88
if you divide this by 9 you get
110 now these are both divisible by 11.
so if you divide by 11 you get 8
you get 8 over
8 over 10 8 over 10 is the same thing as
4 over 5. unbelievable it all simplified
down to four-fifths so the slope of our
line
m squared is equal to four-fifths or
taking the square root of both sides m
is equal to two over
the square root of five so that's the
slope of our line
and now we just have to go back to one
of these equations whichever one we
think is simpler and find the
y-intercept this is the simpler one so b
m is equal to
two over the square root of five
b is going to be equal to b is equal to
the square root of 9 times m squared
remember m squared is four-fifths
four-fifths minus four so what is this
going to be equal to and let me just
clear some of this all of this business
out here since we don't since well i'll
just leave it there maybe it'll be
useful in some way if i made a careless
mistake hopefully i haven't so this is
going to be equal to 9 times 4 is 36 so
it's equal to 36 over 5 minus 20 over 5
minus 20 over 5.
so this is equal to the square root of
16 over 5.
i'm running out of space so this is
equal to so b is equal to the square 36
minus 20 is 16. so square root of 16
over square root of 5
or 4 over the square root of 5. and we
are done we now know
the slope of that tangent line the thing
that had a positive slope its equation
is going to be y is equal to 2 over the
square root of 5 x
plus
4 over the square root of 5. and if we
want to simplify it because if i
remember properly that problem didn't
have it they put everything on the right
hand side let's multiply everything
times square to five so you get square
root of five y is equal to
two x plus four
and then we can subtract these from both
sides and we get negative two x plus the
square root of five y
minus 4
is equal to 0. so do they have that as
one of the choices
so
it looks like they do if we just
multiply everything times negative 1. if
we multiply everything times negative 1
we get 2x
we get 2x minus the square root of 5y
plus 4 is equal to 0
and we are done this was probably the
most painful problem i've done in my
life 2x minus the square root of 5y plus
4. the answer the answer is b